lateral ismo apertura e inclusión el
principal foro de cooperación
internacional celebró su primer día de
cumbre predicando repetitivamente estas
palabras en un discurso que le apuesta a
la lucha conjunta para rescatar al mundo
de los estragos de la crisis sanitaria
el objetivo durante este fin de semana
es consensuar medidas para centrarse en
una recuperación económica con la
promesa de que ésta sea justa y
sostenible el rey salman bin abdulaziz
de arabia saudita habló desde riad y le
dijo a los países participantes que el
desafío para enfrentar la crisis es de
todos
nuestros pueblos y economías siguen
sufriendo este impacto
sin embargo haremos todo lo posible para
superar esta crisis mediante la
cooperación internacional
la vacuna contra el cob y 19 y su
accesibilidad por los países menos
desarrollados fue uno de los puntos en
que coincidieron varios de los líderes
alemania insistió en una mayor inversión
en las instituciones multilaterales el
presidente francés señaló la necesidad
evitar a toda costa el escenario de un
mundo a dos velocidades mientras que el
mandatario mexicano dijo que la pandemia
se debe combatir sin afán de lucro la
salud es un derecho humano fundamental
que el estado tiene que garantizar
haciendo a un lado el afán de lucro
la atención médica
las vacunas y las medicinas
deben ser gratuitas a los líderes de
reino unido y brasil se unieron al
llamado de cooperación mientras que uno
de los más criticados fue el mandatario
estadounidense quien participó en el
inicio de la cumbre y poco después se
fue a jugar golf pese a los más de 12
millones de contagios por ccoo y 19 y
las 255 mil muertes que se han
registrado en eeuu